rund um die erde sind etwa 500 mini
satelliten unterwegs und verfolgen die
signale von flugzeugen schiffen und
warenströmen machen wettervorhersagen
besser und entdecken überschwemmungen
waldbrände und so weiter in echtzeit
genau wie die konsequenzen des
klimawandels bald sollen sie auch die
entlegensten regionen der welt mit dem
globalen computer netzwerk verbinden in
den nächsten zehn jahren könnten es rund
6000 satelliten werden aber auch
nachrichtendienste und das militär
springe ich jetzt darauf an warum genau
diese branche so explodiert was die mini
satelliten alles können und welche
risiken sich hinter diesen wert
beobachtungen verbergen das alles und
noch viel mehr jetzt bei klicks zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
am ende des videos habe ich noch ein
bussi für euch ein gratis exemplar der
zeitschrift technology review sehr cool
in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion ist
dieses video entstanden
ja etwa 500 kilometer hoch fliegen die
mini satelliten und zwar jeden tag exakt
zur selben uhrzeit über denselben punkt
der erdoberfläche ihre kameras machen
dabei ununterbrochen bilder allein 88
der insgesamt 104 satelliten die im
letzten jahr vom indischen
raumfahrtzentrum ins all gebracht wurden
stammen von dem kalifornischen
unternehmen planet ihre mini satelliten
nennen sie darf es also tauben diese
sind gut vier kilogramm schwer und so
groß wie drei clubs setzen diese zahl
100 vier satelliten auf einen streich
ist tatsächlich weltrekord und zeigt wie
krass diese branche explodiert planet
verspricht seinen kunden eine
tagesaktuelle abdeckung der erdland
massen aber sie sind nicht allein da
oben mehr als 500 mini satelliten
kümmern sich um wettervorhersagen oder
die transponder signale von flugzeugen
und schiffen aber auch waldbrände und
überschwemmungen werden in echtzeit
angezeigt ein kanadisches start up hat
eine software entwickelt die auf den
satellitenbildern basiert und der
regierung alle waldbrände mit teil zu
dem auch eine prognose wie sich diese
weiter ausbreiten werden in zukunft
sollen die bilder dann milliarden von
sensoren und schlauer geräte in
entlegenen regionen der welt mit dem
globalen computer netzwerk verbinden als
teil des internets der dinge vorbei sind
die zeiten in denen sich nur wenige
firmen satelliten leisten konnten
doch damals waren die
noch lange nicht so mini sondern eher so
groß wie ein reisebus und das machte
ihren bau und ihrem start so aufwendig
ganz anders sieht das bei den kleinen
satelliten aus die direkt in rauen
mengen
ja durch nur eine rakete ins all
gebracht werden dazu kommen neue
technische lösungen die das alles
möglich machen durch künstliche
intelligenz können die unmengen an daten
überhaupt erst ausgewertet werden auch
solarzellen leistungsfähige batterien
hochauflösende mini kameras und
geschrumpfte schaltkreise machen den
erfolg überhaupt erst möglich
wie an einer perlenkette aufgereiht
ziehen die kaufen ihre bahnen im
sogenannten sonnen synchronen orbit
linie für linie entsteht so tag für tag
ein bild der kompletten land masse des
planeten und das mit einer auflösung von
drei bis fünf metern es gibt aber auch
noch hochgenaue satelliten mit 70
zentimeter auf lösungen auch eine neue
denkweise hat dazu geführt den
fachkreisen auch als das angel aerospace
genannt also so etwas wie die agile luft
und raumfahrt hier zeigt man mut zum
scheitern
weder zeit noch geld werden verpulvert
um jede einzelne kleine schrauben für
den einsatz im weltraum fit zu machen
stattdessen zeigen die unternehmen mut
zur lücke und nehmen start und fälle
gerne in kauf 2014 beispielsweise
explodierte eine amerikanische und ares
rakete und 26 satelliten von planet
waren auf einmal verloren den ausbau der
flotte verzögerte das aber nur um wenige
monate das alles also der einfache
aufbau und der geringe preis bedeutet
natürlich auch abstriche gemacht werden
müssen die satelliten hat meist nicht
länger als vier jahre die strategie
möglichst viele einzusetzen macht den
ausfall dann aber wieder wett denn dann
übernimmt eben ein anderer satellit
zudem haben die unternehmen so die
möglichkeit die hardware immer weiter zu
entwickeln
gefeilt werden soll demnächst
beispielsweise noch an der
datenübertragung und den aufgenommenen
wellenlängen angedacht sind auch
triebwerke mit denen die mini satelliten
in zukunft aufgerüstet werden könnten
der markt wird auf mehr als 30
milliarden dollar geschätzt
denn in den nächsten zehn jahren wird
mit insgesamt 6200 kleinen satelliten im
all
rechnet doch dazu müssen noch einige
faktoren optimiert werden per anhalter
ins all zu kommen ist von der logistik
her sehr aufwendig die termine sind rar
und die umlaufbahn der großen satelliten
entsprechen nicht den bahnen der club
setzt die zukunft könnte in mini raketen
liegen also sowie die elektro von roccat
lab ohne viel schnickschnack dafür eine
elektrisch betriebene turbo pumpe aus
dem 3d drucker 49.000 dollar pro
kilogramm nutzlast ist hier der preis
insgesamt kann die rakete 150 kilogramm
transportieren
der transport ist zwar teurer als
beispielsweise die mitfahrgelegenheit
auf der verein von spacex aber dafür
exklusiv und solch ein kleines system
kann durchaus häufiger statt derzeit
laufen unzählige projekte die in diese
richtung gehen zudem müsste eine weitere
bedingung eingelöst werden damit der
markt weiter so ausgebaut werden kann
mit der zeit die bilder müssten einen
deutlichen mehrwert bieten schon jetzt
nutzen kunden die mini satelliten um
beispielsweise den armuts index eines
landes zu bestimmen
beispielsweise indem sie die ziegel und
strohdächer in ländlichen gegenden
zählen auch die abholzung der wälder
wird beispielsweise in peru oder vietnam
mit hilfe der bilder beobachtet und
dokumentiert und selbst die sklaverei
kann somit aufgedeckt werden wie es
beispielsweise einem forschungsteam aus
großbritannien gelungen ist und zwar
durch das aufspüren so genannter
ziegelstein gürtel gürteln also regionen
in denen sich ziegelei an ziegelei
wright hier werden menschen oft als
zwangsarbeiter ausgebeutet bisher werden
noch freiwillige die bilderauswahl hofft
hier auf künstliche intelligenz die
selbst solche region identifizieren soll
dass die blending trägt hier seinen teil
bei und in den letzten jahren wurden
große erfolge im bereich der
automatischen bildverarbeitung gemacht
doch die lassen sich leider nicht eins
zu eins auf satellitenbilder übertragen
denn dort gibt es mehr als die üblichen
drei farbkanäle doch in zukunft soll es
auch nicht bei standbildern bleiben ein
startup aus den usa mit dem namen will
demnächst live aufnahmen von jedem punkt
der erde liefern
damit ließ sich so einiges beobachten
unkontrollierte waldbrände illegale
fischerei oder aber die wanderin
wanderung von google an und stellt euch
mal vor ihr hätte google maps mit einer
live satelliten karte ziemlich stand
eine intelligente bildverarbeitung würde
die datenmenge reduzieren und so zitat
veränderungen viel besser erkennen und
den globalen puls der erde quasi
fortwährend messen das sagt da mehr an
bord abteilungsleiter die burning beim
deutschen forschungszentrum für
künstliche intelligenz dfg in
kaiserslautern zu dem geplanten youtube
aus dem all
das alles ist für die einen eine mega
kracher vorstellung für die anderen ist
der reinste horror
datenschützer beispielsweise reagieren
äußerst nervös auf solche ankündigungen
denn auch wenn die beteiligten
unternehmen oft ihren sozialen nutzen in
den vordergrund stellen kommt das große
geld woanders her blendet beispielsweise
hat einen vertrag mit der us behörde für
geheimdienstliche aufklärung ebenso mit
spionage agenturen und auch das militär
zeigt sich interessiert aber auch
datenreihen für einen anderen kontext
sind bereits im angebot beispielsweise
von dem kalifornischen start up little
insight nämlich dazu wie gut parkplätze
von supermärkten genutzt werden oder
auch zum weltweiten abbau von eisenerz
diese infos zeigen sehr genau wo die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hingeht bei
diesem konkreten beispiel eben ob ein
supermarkt kurz davor ist bleibt zu
gehen oder ob der laden derzeit ganz gut
läuft ja vielen dank an technology
review in zusammenarbeit mit der
redaktion dieser ziemlich
kunstzeitschrift ist dieses video
entstanden und exklusiv für pixum
zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk
ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis
wenn ihr auf diesen link klickt das
lohnt sich wirklich
ja und hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken hobby-astronom finde
totgeglaubten nasa satelliten bis dann
bleibt dran